all right guys
bang bang i've got john here uh
he's a legend we're just leave it at
that
although most people when you put out
that you were interviewing me their
their number one question was who who is
this guy
well you know you you have to learn the
first rule of twitter which is never
read the comments because uh whether
they're good or bad they're not good to
read right
yeah that's that's definitely true all
right
let's go through your background before
you started cheddar you got it
what did you get i just go i just go
yeah just go have you done a podcast
before
uh yeah i think yeah i've done like
brian morrissey's digi day podcast yeah
all right
all right so we're the second podcast
you're doing you just talk and i'll
interrupt you and when you need to shut
up
okay i give i give very concise answers
too that's kind of what i what i do as
well
all right so uh very winding and
meandering uh career path
um the highlights were i was a disney
imagineer
in high school an intern i got that
through basically writing them a letter
as a kid and it was kind of like the
movie big
so i used to go out to burbank and work
on theme park attractions and i did that
from basically
15 to 20. um so that was really cool
then my career did not so great
and i got stuck being a consultant at
booz allen after business school
i'm skipping around i kind of felt like
a child star who had had this bright
period of time and then now i was
working in a
office park in northern virginia um
and so then i thought my career was over
but then through a series of lucky
happenstances i got hired into google to
work on partnership deals as a very
you know low level junior type person
but that was good experience
and then a couple other hops and i
became president of buzzfeed i met jonah
i became president buzzfeed 15th
employee very little revenue when i
joined
i think we got it to 50 or 60 million
when i left four years later
um then i did a stint
being president of uh or ceo of daily
mail north america
the mail online and then founded cheddar
in 20
uh 2016 january 2016 started cheddar
and that's it let's talk about buzzfeed
real quick
yeah i feel like that was so disruptive
when you guys were really scaling
yeah what was that experience like the
experience of buzzfeed was
that you can have each of these startups
is a series of bets right you place bets
and if one of the big bets works out
you're generally in a good spot and if
two of the big bets work out
then you know it's like it's like it's
like pocket aces basically right pocket
aces and then you hit like an ace on the
flop or something like that
and and we we had two bets and um
the first was jonah's bet jonah paredi
the founders bet
that that social traffic would be
enormous and facebook would send
enormous amount of traffic
to sites that created content that
worked well on social
and then my bet was that native
advertising creating advertorials
digital laboratorials
would be a great advertising product in
the face
of banners which were still being sold
direct in 2010
and um for a while that bet didn't look
so good 2010 2011 were very tough
advertising wasn't really picking up
social traffic wasn't really coming
and then 2012 both hit like like
lightning
and that's what made that work got it
and so
when you then go to start cheddar what
were the two bets
the two bets with cheddar were that live
would be a big thing that people would
want live content nobody was really
doing anything
live and that there would be all of
these ott systems like sling tv and what
have you
um that would want live content and we
could be there and in this new universe
there would be no difference between
us and cnbc and cnn and
also subsequently after a couple
different you know revenue models
we hit on this kind of live read branded
content type product
that worked really well as well now the
part of the bet that i got wrong
and it took a while for me to get it
wrong but luckily we corrected it was
these free tv systems they're called
fast
free ad supported television like pluto
and roku channel
samsung tv plus those became
those came out of nowhere like a tidal
wave it became giant
and the virtual mvpd's like sling and
youtube tv while very important partners
to us and and
you know incredible systems didn't have
nearly the scale and the growth that the
free tv systems would have but we were
we were quick enough to make sure that
we were on the free tv systems
and so did that change what the content
or just the way you guys approached it
like what changed when those fast
systems came
uh on the market well you know for
a while we had two networks right we had
one network which was designed for the
pay tv ecosystem
and we had one network which was
designed for the free tv ecosystem
and then during covid we did a layoff
and we also did a collapse of the two
networks into one network
because you know i mean advertising was
very tough during covet
um and so we were able to kind of knit
it all together into one thing but for a
while we were basically operating almost
like two parallel networks to service
each of these different platforms
got it uh one of the things that uh
cheddar was well known for at one point
was
the um trading floor location
and also the flatiron location yeah
what was the fascination with getting
kind of cool
memorable locations to actually record
from
live television is a window on the world
people watch live television in the same
way they look out the window especially
when it's news they want to see like
what's going on in the world
and to the extent that you can provide
that there's an aura that comes with it
that makes it much more compelling than
if you're just in a studio and so
we were covering the stock market and
companies
and the trading floor is the
incarnation of business and markets and
also by the way
all these amazing companies come through
there every day to ring the bell
uh and so that to me was the most
important piece in launching the network
was that we get on the floor of the
stock exchange
and uh went to tom farley who was the
ceo of the new york stock exchange at
the time or the president
and i'd been on cnbc a lot as a
contributor so he and i had gotten to be
acquaintances
and i laid out this vision of what i
wanted to create i wanted to create a
cnbc for millennials and i was going to
deliver in all these new places and it
was going to be on social
and right away he was like okay you know
we don't have much to lose if if you do
well you can stay and if it doesn't
really go anywhere we're gonna
boot you out and you know that was
we got going right away he put you
in like the smallest place i've ever
seen i was on cheddar once or twice
and literally it was like wedged into
what was most people
largest set on the floor of the new york
stock exchange that set is
cnbc's is massive cbc has an entire post
right yep
our thing is bigger than what fox
business has and bigger than what you
know bloomberg
has there so look space is at a premium
i mean the only space more
people than the floor of the new york
stock exchange is maybe like you know
park avenue in the 70s but like other
than that
um you know i i would i would have taken
a postage stamp if that's
that was the space that he gave me yeah
well i was i was going to say like you
obviously wanted to be there because
where they put you even if it's the
second biggest one
it was just such like a unique spot in
between the trading little pits or
whatever
yeah it's like wedged between our space
is wedged between
two trading pods basically it's it's
like it's almost like
if we weren't using it it would
basically be storage space
absolutely so uh you also ended up going
in a very interesting distribution uh
kind of strategy so you already talked
about the fast systems you talked about
a number of these like ott platforms uh
i remember you did deals
uh if i remember correctly at one point
cheddar was getting streamed to
gas stations gstv we are still in the
gas stations
all right well explain that one so there
is this thing called gstb
run by this guy sean mccafferty great
guy
um and most gas stations you go to i
find it's most gasoline
i used to travel quite a bit i don't
travel anymore because no one travels
anymore but like most gas stations you
go to
on the pump there's a tv screen and that
tv screen
runs commercials and news and basically
every time i've ever been
in here once the news update is running
is the cheddar news update you know
our anchor baker machado is is the is
the gas station tv
anchor basically uh and it's great it
gets the brand out there
um you know people hear what cheddar is
for the first time everybody makes fun
of it which means they're seeing it you
know people make fun of you
that that's when you really know that
you're uh
that they that they know who you are and
they're hearing you is when they make
fun of you
absolutely uh another deal you did was
uh at one point you were getting like
licensed or streamed to college campuses
i think of course i still have that
so we bought from viacom viacom had this
thing called mtvu
which is screens that are in cafeterias
gyms and student unions
that were hard-coded to mtv basically
playing music videos
we bought that from them it's 1400
screens on 400 campuses
and changed it to cheddar and we call it
cheddar u and so
we have the largest basically college
network
large largest college audience
place-based college audience
of anybody through having cheddar years
so we have that as well too look i've
been obsessed with distribution i mean
if your content is great you know
and it's not distributed properly um
no one's gonna see it and there's a lot
of content that's so
so but has great distribution and you
know
gets seen by plenty of people and so you
know
distribution is probably more important
than content and content's probably
number two
uh there's a y combinator saying that
first-time entrepreneurs worry about
product second time entrepreneurs worry
about distribution
and i think that that's you know a
perfect example here how did that
change the conversation with advertisers
one just as you got larger and larger
i'm sure that helped
but two around where you had the
distribution so
it's one thing to say hey people are
coming to our website it's a whole other
thing to say
you know gas stations college campuses
ott et cetera well the most important
thing that's happened now is we have
enough scale on these fast
systems that we can run standard 15 and
30 second
commercials right and that's really
important because advertisers want
simple turnkey solutions right
where we've continued to struggle is
with measurement which is that there's
no
nielsen number for all the places we're
in there's no single com score number
although we're getting columns for and
so
that's been measurement has probably
been one of the greatest difficulties
of the business has been probably the
most great difficulty
got it uh you eventually sold the
business uh for a big number
um i'm assuming you other shareholders
did very well in that
uh why'd you sell it well so you know
actually what's interesting about it is
i think we did well for the investors
and i think it was a great outcome the
people who put in early money made
a great return on it i think that for a
lot of our investors you know it wasn't
quite a silicon valley
return because they didn't get to put as
much money to work
as they would would have liked and so i
think that you know the investors were
happy and i think that i have a great
relationship with them and they would
certainly
uh back me again but you know most
firms are looking for multi-billion
dollar exits and you know a 200 million
dollar exit doesn't really move the
needle
for most of these firms right so um
that's just a bit of a side note why did
i sell the business because i looked out
and everything was getting
bigger and more consolidated and
um you know nbc universal was owned by
comcast
fox was sold to disney um you know we
were always the only
independent you look you look on hulu
live or you look on sling and it's cnbc
which is owned by att
it's um msnbc which is owned by comcast
it's and and you know when i started
the company i felt a bit like i was
running around with a bb gun
and everybody else had you know muskets
right
and then over the course of four years
it began to feel like you know
i no longer had a bb gun maybe i had
like a slingshot now because
you know we'd improve but they had
developed
you know extensive arsenals of weapons
right
and so we it was natural to link up with
them it was also natural like about
altis because they were
exclusively news focused you know the
other part of the portfolio is news 12
these hyper local news stations
so the company basically decided that
they were going to be in
telecommunications broadband television
you know telephony and news and they
weren't going to be in dramas and
comedies and so this was the perfect
kind of addition to that portfolio
i had had all teas as investors i think
for
three two three years at that point so
they knew the company inside and out
um and it was the right time and you
know also i mean
covet coven ended up coming as well too
now i didn't know cobin was coming
but i'm certainly lucky to have the
support of a large corporate parent to
kind of get through covid
whereas i think that would have been
unbelievably difficult as a standalone
startup so
you know that i can't really claim that
that factored into the decision but i
think it certainly made the decision
more right in retrospect
a lot of people in america don't think
know about all teas yeah
would you agree with that actually let
me answer your question a little more
about why
i sold as well too is that you know i
i really think that you know i've told
jessica lesson this when she interviewed
me is that media is really about
you know independent media companies are
like drug discovery
you know you're developing a drug you've
heard me say this before
no but i i i can already see where this
is going and i like it so keep going
and so you develop a great drug so let's
say cheddar
we developed an amazing drug for uh
arthritis
great on great arthritis drug we had
great scientists we developed a great
arthritis drug blah blah blah
okay now we have a choice we have to go
through fda trials now that's going to
cost
gillions of dollars then we need an
entire pharmaceutical sales force then
we need an entire
you know production line to get this
thing out there and
for most media companies trying to do
that is a mistake
they're literally reinventing the wheel
and they're reinventing the wheel
when people already have a wheel and the
only unique thing that they've really
brought to the table is their unique new
drug that they did through r d
and so that's why it is the right
decision for morning brew to sell
to business insider for you know i came
what was the number quoted 75
uh i think that is the alleged number
yes right because what are they gonna do
build an entire sales force
build an entire cms build a research
division build
all these things that axel springer and
business insider have
and look the history of media companies
independent media companies is that
they get too large they've they've built
up this infrastructure the
infrastructure's not
necessarily as doesn't have the margins
that the other people have the
incumbents have
and then they're sort of too big
basically i mean that's
that's what happens when you get too big
in media yeah
uh patrick draghi who uh i think owns
all teas
okay he fascinates me because he's a
multi-billionaire
uh there are almost no interviews with
him anywhere
yeah i'm seeing him tomorrow for
breakfast i'll tell him that you uh
you should tell him to come on the show
for sure
unlike unlikely yeah i figured it's
unlikely
uh what what's it been like or kind of
what have you learned from being around
somebody like that
who i think just most people look and
say look he's built this amazing
very large uh company obviously one that
you found attractive to kind of partner
with and
and go work with kind of anything there
in terms of just the way that the
company operates or patrick specifically
so he's a genius you know and and i
would say the culture
most of my interaction i'm privileged to
be able to interact with patrick on a
routine basis and but my boss is dexter
goey who's the ceo of altis right and
dexter's been working with patrick
for a very long time i think over a
decade or something like that
and the way patrick and dexter work
is they're very calm they're very steady
and they have a sense of humor about
everything right and they know their
numbers
cold and that's basically
and also you know they understand that
that most businesses are operated
inefficiently and there is margin to be
derived from
almost from almost any business right
and so
that steadiness that facility with my
numbers
i mean you know i'm going to see patrick
tomorrow i'm walking in there this is
just a casual ketchup i'm walking in
there with
a stack of printouts like this and my
laptop because like he's just going to
ask me
some number you know and uh and
it's always a little bit like an exam
but you know i did well in school and i
know how to study
so you know i love it what's the biggest
focus for you right now
uh at altis as you kind of scale the
business
you know we have two advertising
products that i'm really trying to grow
you know we have the local advertising
business
which is selling um spots throughout our
footprint
on our cable system uh and that that's a
very steady business that's doing quite
well and then we have the emerging
products which are basically the cheddar
product the sponsored content and we're
also selling we have an advanced
advertising division that allows us to
sell
national advertising that can be
targeted and have conversion tracked by
ip so i would say
innovation and that i would say that
from the content standpoint
news 12 we've done an extensive kind of
rebrand and regraphic and
re-modernization of that over the past
few
um over the past year really and then
with
cheddar um you know trying to make
figure out these fast systems figure out
which ones are going to be the biggest
making sure that we're there making sure
we have the channel position
you know we launched on 2b we launched
cheddar and news 12
on 2b um last week which is kind of
amazing i've been pushing
the 2b folks for a long time to do news
because i felt like it was
one of the giant platforms that didn't
have news um
but i'd like our content to be
everywhere on these fast systems even
the ones like you know peacock that
haven't put us on yet
so uh before we get into kind of a
couple of topics i'm just gonna throw
out and you mind dump on us your
thoughts
uh what about netflix peacock you know
these other platforms
um do you see them eventually adding
news and you guys being a contender
there
or do you think like maybe a netflix
just they'll never get into anything
i was in i was in a uh somebody held a
thing with reed hastings i think one of
my professors and i asked a question i
said reed i've been
and i i've had two interactions with
reed in the past however many
years one was at dld in munich and then
the last was this one a few weeks ago in
both cases i asked him
when are you gonna do news and in both
cases he told me you know
no plans right and so i don't see them
doing it peacock has some news on it
you know they have they have the nbc
universal news on it whether or not they
open it up to other people's news
is yet to be seen amazon we have a great
relationship with amazon on the fire
platform
has fire news so it's it's a dedicated
square on
if you have a fire stick and we're one
of the newest providers there so in some
ways that's an alternative to prime
um and so you know and disney plus i
don't really see doing it i mean look it
bums me out it bums me out that
you know netflix and disney plus like
two of the biggest and fast growing
um don't have news what bums me less is
if they decided tomorrow to put on news
um they would do one of two things
either disney would decide
they were only doing abc okay
or if they decide to let other people on
we would definitely get the phone call
because we always get the phone call
when people decide they want to put
news on because we have a high quality
product and it's free
and that's that's that's a winning
combination for people that need
news content makes sense uh you've been
live video uh at cheddar for a long time
talk to me about audio do you guys rip
the
audio from the videos and put them out
as podcasts have you thought about
podcasts kind of what's going on there
so we do the audio simulcast we do on
tune in
and iheart and a few others uh we don't
get very good statistics on it i don't
really know what the
listenership is there podcasts i've
completely stayed away from you know
it's too competitive
um it is personality driven
uh and you either need a big personality
uh that draws an audience or
true crime and those seem to me to be
like the two categories that really work
right and um you know
we cheddar was always
an ensemble cast type thing always more
of a news type thing and we don't
have the stars is really the wrong
word we don't have the people like
barstool has that are able to really
gather
loyal followings kind of by personality
and so that would make a per that would
make a podcast i think very hard for us
to do
newsletters we do we bought need to know
you know which was kind of like a
smaller version of the skim i think it
has three or four hundred thousand subs
uh it does okay for us but you know look
you can only do one thing when you're a
startup really you know and you can
not that we're startup anymore now we're
part of this larger thing but really
video
has been my sole focus for the past four
and a half years and i think is going to
be my sole focus for the
for the coming future um i think that
we're the best at live video
i think that we have made it our sole
focus and i think that that's what we're
going to continue to focus
certainly for another year or two what
about outside of you guys right so you
guys stay with live video but what do
you just think about
kind of the rise of newsletters and this
whole kind of uh phenomenon that's going
on
yeah i mean you and i have talked about
this before i think the amazing thing
about the newsletter
thing is that if you're a writer
and you're part of a media company and
you can go
sign up a thousand people at a hundred
dollars a year
you know that's pretty incredible right
and i'm not sure how many people can do
that but look you just you know casey
from
the verge just left to go he's on sub
stack
he is yeah and he's gonna probably make
more money than he makes at the verge
and he's probably going to have uh a
better lifestyle and make more money and
you know and own 100 of what he creates
and so
um i think it's really disruptive to
to printed to print journalism print
digital journalism absolutely what about
uh other forms of video so not live
video but whether it's kind of the tick
tock and short form
type stuff whether it's more of like the
vlog and the longer form stuff on
youtube
uh but just things that aren't live news
based how do you think about that
i think that you know there hasn't been
a lot of the youtube thing is
we do some youtube we do some explainers
on youtube and they do they do plenty
well
um there hasn't been a lot of innovation
there really you know and tick tock we
were really big on tick tock for a while
we still have a million four followers
on tick tock cheddar does
we do our gadget videos there
monetization really isn't there
you know either and you know for a long
time from my buzzfeed days to my early
cheddar days
you know we were we were going places
where we could get growth and get the
brand out there and it was exciting and
it was the right thing for the company
at the time but now
i'm just much more focused on the
economics of these things um you know
does it make
financial sense for us to be spending
time on this
and so many of these platforms are still
you know
are still nickels and dimes if that i
mean tick tock isn't even nickel and
dimes
yeah uh all of these different platforms
uh are kind of benefiting from the rise
of the creator right i think that we've
always thought about that as like
oh the youtubers and people who had kind
of more
creative type skills and they probably
lack some of the business
um you know interest and uh scalability
and skill set
now it almost feels like we're getting
the opposite right we've got tons and
tons of
business-minded folks who are starting
to be able to build audiences because of
these platforms reducing the friction to
doing that
uh you mentioned bar stool there's a
couple of others that are kind of
leaning into
uh this overlap between the creator or
personality
and and audiences and monetizing it how
do you kind of think through
maybe not for you guys but other media
companies is that something that they're
going to lean in hard on
i think the way that you would do this
is look i'm reading the same articles
everybody's reading you know the one
that taylor lorenz at the new york times
just put out about the tick tockers that
are making millions of dollars and get
free cars to free car leases from
triller and you know all this stuff and
i think that
it goes one of two ways either and look
my kids my 10 and 11 year old they love
charlie and emilio like that's like
that's their favorite person right
and so i think it goes one of two ways
basically
these uber stars on these short form
platforms are able to continue to get
influencer type sponsorships and do
deals
and stuff like that and if that happens
i think they will some of them will
choose to be
rolled up into a company not dissimilar
from what we saw
during you know with the mcns and
youtube back in the day where
all the youtube stars got rolled up into
these companies and then
there were various squabbles and it
didn't really work and then they really
they all decided to
unbundle you know it's sort of
interesting i mean it's like sub stack
is basically
the the bundling of writers with
with the tick tock stars they're all
deep bundled in individuals and out
there doing their influencer deals
and then the question is what makes
sense to to roll up and bundle
into a company and i imagine somebody if
not already will take a pass and making
a company basically
out of tick tock stars what about
monetizing through non-advertising and
non-subscription so subscriptions become
popular with things like sub stack right
for kind of emails and
and that advertising's a known thing
what about things like
uh either in more endorsement type
models uh maybe
even joint ventures or physical products
like
we've seen creators on youtube who maybe
can't monetize very well
on that platform yeah they've had to get
creative does
the large media companies almost use
these creators as like r
d and just take the best practices and
start to monetize in other ways as well
well who's the first creator that that
comes up with the next all birds
right like that that would be super
interesting to see that happen
we've seen all these d2c companies that
are doing well
that make a single product that kind of
reduced the choice for the consumer
which
is really compelling because i think
people want less choice they want to be
told
these are the shoes to get not like you
know select from any number of these
shoes right
and and so i i think that's a viable
model
i think many of the other things you
talked about are really kind of just
advertising
in in another in another word basically
sponsorships or branding i mean it's
that's all basically forms of
advertising but when you get right down
to it you
basically have three avenues for
monetizing media as far as i can tell
you've got
to your point subscription advertising
and e-commerce the bloom is a little bit
off of e-commerce i mean there were a
bunch of media companies that went into
it but basically amazon took down the
affiliate payments that they were giving
people
these ecommerce things typically have
very low margin because selling physical
products has very low margin which is
why
there's amazon and basically nobody else
um
but there may be this little carve out
of these d2c
high-end custom products that
influencers may be able to get into
and make e-commerce a go but look
advertising and subscription have been
around
for you know hundreds if not
a thousand years basically as the two
major forms of
media monetization yeah i keep thinking
about this idea of you know
joe rogan rather than uh have to sponsor
traeger grills he should have just said
hey i want the joe rogan grill it's a
trigger girl with the joe rogan logo he
sells it through to his audience
owns equity gets a higher percentage
than just the ad dollars
or you even go to you know uh take a d2c
company like maybe casper right i don't
know their exact numbers but
somewhere where there's very high cost
of acquisition and you almost have them
eventually get bought by like
the rock and the rock says hey this is
the best mattress i work out hard and
then i go to sleep every night
and you can drastically reduce the cat i
wonder how much of
the economics of that are already
captured through advertising and through
referral and you know this thing about
joe rogan is i started listening to joe
rogan
uh only two weeks ago just because i
kind of wanted to you know i just
who'd you listen what episode you listen
to i listened to the one where he was
talking to a
psychologist about narcissism okay then
i listened to the episode where he was
talking to colin quinn
yep okay so you haven't listened to any
of the super super
uh out there once yet no i just want to
listen to the most current ones right
and
um and i had listened to parts of the
elon musk one a little
way back when um i was shocked by how
many live read commercials he had
at the beginning he has like seven
minutes eight minutes i mean right
and but what i recognized is oh all you
have to do is just skip to the
you just drag the slider and you don't
have to listen to eight minutes of
sponsors so i don't know how sustainable
that really is and
and i mean his his podcasts are super
long so i've never listened through but
there's no commercials in the middle
right
none so i but but he's using referral
codes so i mean i guess most people
don't skip the commercials and i guess
he's getting great brands to do this
stuff with him
yeah oh you know i mean look it it is
fascinating right i mean everybody who's
a
loyal listener knows you can just hit
the fast forward button you hear the
music
right and then you kind of just undo it
and that's where the episode's going to
start
but again you know how many people
actually fast forward
i'm sure some percentage but back to
what you're saying you know on the
grills right
which is you know i believe he's
capturing the vast majority of the
economics
of his contribution to what's the name
of the grill company you mentioned
traeger grills is his big one of his big
sponsors trigger
traeger
we're running ads for him right now look
at us yeah i i think that he's
he's capturing the value he's creating
for traeger because they're probably
paying him a very
high referral per grill right i'm not
sure him going through the trouble
of buying or owning the grill company or
starting the grill company
would really work although ironically
we're talking about grills and you know
george foreman i i i
i suspect that the george foreman grill
worked out very well for him i mean he
did it for many years obviously
it must have been working and um you
know maybe it's a little bit of
experimentation of both
i mean i do think there are categories
that are super cheap to produce in
where brand is really important and
rogan could be very successful because
he's also all about like
health and martial arts and things like
that as well too and he does a
commercial one of his commercials is for
a
supplement or a greens type drink you
know
i bet a lot of people would buy joe
rogan vitamins or joe rogan
you know he actually is a equity owner
in uh in a company
that uh natural greens or something i
think it was
uh oh maybe he ran an athletic greens
athletic reads athletic green okay so
he's not an equity owner there as far as
i know
he's got he's got it for company um the
areas that you're most interested in
outside of live television
like we could talk about all these
different things like where do you see
the biggest opportunity if you were
going to go restart uh
a new media company today where would
you look
i think that
media is not where media is not the uh
the only media ideas i have kicking
around in my head are the media ideas
for my my job really just because it
kind of sucks up some one only has so
much media frontal lobe right
i think financial services there's a lot
to be done in financial services and i
think
that you've seen parts of the stack
already being taken apart and being done
by startups like lemonade for insurance
or robinhood for stock trading or
acorns for saving and i think that's
really just the tip of the iceberg i
think that there is
you know i was actually looking at um
wealthfront for the first time last
night a friend of mine pulled up
wealthfront because you know
wealth management is one of the areas
that's kind of interesting to me and i
was surprised by sort of how basic it
was and how many things you couldn't do
and so to me i think that we'll
you know we'll see every every type of
insurance and every type of financial
product
startupized and that's much earlier
innings i think
than what we've seen in media the other
thing i'll tell you is you know i bought
a used car over the summer through
carvana
and you know i can't imagine ever going
back to buying a car
any other way i mean so you know that's
an example too
of just just how much things can be done
online and differently and in a modern
fashion
so uh i had a um uh one of the founders
of carlipso which was
bought by uh carvana come on and this
week i've recorded three podcasts
where the guest mentioned buying a car
on carvana this year
right i mean just floating the selection
is not even that good like the
selection's not that good i wanted a
pickup truck
and like they only had like a handful
that fit like
low mileage and what i wanted and you
know the super cab and all that type of
stuff
so i could fit the kids in it but they
make it so easy
and you know there's no fighting over
the price the price is set you can go
and check the blue book to make sure
that it's you know
it's within range and it's and i had
gone i had gone to a dealership before
and i was immediately you know arguing
with the guy over price and the prices
didn't make any sense
and it's a far better experience i mean
i can't imagine why
anyone would do anything other than buy
a car online yeah
it makes sense you've been uh heavily
involved in the
startup world and in investing what are
some of the other themes that you find
interesting right now or that you're
looking to invest in
so i don't really invest that much i you
know i it's very rare that i do
investment
for me i love operating and i find
investing to be really frustrating
because
i just want to take the steering wheel
you know and i think that like
you know so i i don't in the few things
that i've invested in
but mostly it's a relatively
uncomfortable thing for me so i like
personal finance is super interesting um
connected fitness
i don't think is tapped out yet peloton
and mirror
you know are are great and are big but i
don't think they're the only ones that
can come into that i think that that's
a mega trend that's here to stay um
i think that there will be more fast tv
services
i don't think we're done with that yet i
don't think there's enough of them and i
think that
they'll be customized to different
interests and likes um
coffee recently i've i've experimented
with coffee there's there's two coffee
startups that interest me
uh i'm not an investor in either they're
just interesting one is jot coffee which
is super concentrated coffee then you
just put another the other is this thing
called
commenter which is frozen it comes
frozen the coffee
coffee pods come frozen you boil a cup
of water you put the coffee pod into it
um that's that's
are you a big coffee drinker yeah i'm a
big coffee drinker yeah i
even have a coffee tattoo no you don't
really yeah
you you those who are just listening
we're about to see uh a coffee tattoo
oh he he legitimately has a coffee
tattoo i've got one i got a coffee
tattoo
so and then that's scotch
scotch that's fantastic
although although i'm not drinking now i
am doing like the dry
uh sober october sober october yeah all
right dry october
how many cups of coffee do you have a
day
i've ebbed and flowed over time because
you know my doctors want me to have less
um but i have three four cups of coffee
a day
all right this is a really important
thing like like literally
breaks friendships are you an iced
coffee drinker
i saw your tweet about that i saw your
tweet about that did you drink iced
coffee
i drink iced coffee you're right drink
iced coffee in the winter yeah of course
all right we're friends still i i think
that basically
iced coffee is the afternoon beverage so
like you know
uh oh do you go hot coffee in the
morning and iced coffee in the afternoon
yeah cause i i need to warm myself up i
need to warm up my
my chili bones in the morning you know
like i need a hot coffee you know i do
i do believe that consuming a cold
beverage on a cold day in the morning
and i walk my daughter to the school bus
like you know it'll put it it'll put a
chill in you if you have
you know an iced coffee first thing in
the morning i don't think i know a
single person who
goes hot and cold in the same day do you
have do you use an ultra concentrate
coffee
no you should you would love it i mean
it's actually perfect for iced coffee
what are you brewing
are you cold brewing or what are you
doing i i get my ass up and i walk to
starbucks and i go and i order coffee
you know you should be going to duncan
my friend my
my great partner duncan is where you
should be going listen
uh dunkin donuts everyone knows america
runs on duncan
america runs on duncan cheddar runs on
duncan
all right i asked the same two questions
everybody before we finish up
and you get to ask me one to finish it
uh first one is what's the most
important book you've ever read
it's a great question atlas shrugged
probably why
because i think that i think
ann rand is
widely misquoted and misunderstood and
people basically use it as an excuse
for being totally capitalistic and
having no social welfare net and i don't
i don't buy into any of that
i i believe the society needs to take
care of its
of its population and the capitalism
alone is not perfect so i'm not i'm not
like crazy on it
but the notion of the creator
and the value that the inventor brings
to society and the role that capitalism
plays in moving a world forward really
spoke to me
and so that book was sort of formative
and kind of how i i think i
shaped my entrepreneurial mindset so
there was that book
catcher in the rye i really like a lot
too
um the idea that as we all come of age
there's this discomfort and adjusting to
the old
the adult world and figuring out where
one fits in
um robert robert carro's book the power
broker about robert moses
about how cities get built you know
robert moses was a terrible person but
the book is an amazing book to
understand how cities get built and the
politics that go into them and
how pro how complicated projects are
executed
um i give you three books i guess those
are all great ones
second question more fun aliens are you
a believer or a non-believer
i'm a complete believer why just because
i think
that if the universe is infinite
that the likelihood that we are the only
intelligent life form is just you know
it's just not possible
it's not possible and um and i and i do
think that
you know when you when you hear about
the sightings that people have had and
the experience that people have had
there's a striking similarity in you
know close encounters are the third kind
there's a striking similarity in all of
this stuff
so but you know i tend to be more
open-minded
um you know i am
i'm religious you know i'm jewish i
believe in god i believe that there are
things that happen that are outside of
our control and that there are
forces in the universe that we don't
understand and so i think that
alien sort of plays into that look
aliens you know the other possibility
is that we are all in a in a
terrarium or a fish tank on an alien's
counter
right i mean you know when you have pets
like my cat
my cat's understanding of the world is
very very strange you know she
she's in this she's an indoor cat her
universe is this apartment
and her other universe used to be a
different apartment when we moved
i mean how does my cat possibly
like before my cat doesn't even bother
trying to process that
yeah so i started asking the alien
question because one night i was laying
in bed
and i had this really intelligent
epiphany which was
do you think aliens have pets like
you you have a cat right yeah but like
if the aliens showed up
are they showing up with like multiple
species and and there's
uh pets involved
well you know where my thought first
went to is you know do they have
livestock do they have
working animals and animals that they
breed for food and the likelihood is
that they are more advanced than us and
they've probably already moved off of
a you know an animal-based diet they
probably are on only a plant-based diet
so i would suspect
that the aliens show up without pets or
livestock
that's a contrarian view there my friend
all right what question you got for me
to finish this up
who's the most interesting person that
you've ever interviewed the most
interesting person i've ever
interviewed um
you so interesting is hard because it's
r
because everyone finds different things
interesting but the person that i think
uh was the most misunderstood
and i walked away and i said i could
talk to that person for hours and hours
and hours
and like never get tired of talking to
her
is kathy wood from arkhanvest
i just i done two interviews with her
the first one was like
300 tesla stock price she was given the
whole innovation story and she was
getting
hammered by everyone uh
and you never know like when people go
on television and stuff you're kind of
like hey do they
how how much do they believe what
they're saying and kind of what's that
conviction look like
and uh i remember coming out of the
first conversation being like
that woman really understands technology
trends really understands innovation
really has kind of that independent
thinking and first principles thinking
um and the second time we did it uh
tesla had run
um so everyone kind of shut up about
that now they were on to the next thing
you know saying that that she was wrong
on
uh but i just think that it's
fascinating to find somebody who's had a
very
long storied career uh and reached a
point where like
she's probably just as hungry now as she
always was uh
and just enjoys playing the game right
and so it's just like all those little
pieces to it should probably be the
answer
good answer all right where can people
find you on the internet
john steinberg on twitter all right
we're gonna have to do this again in the
future
i think i feel like uh maybe i'm gonna
have to come back with like a coffee
tattoo or something myself now to uh to
one up
nice coffee tattoo all right we'll do it
again in the future
pleasure thanks for the time